hey so I'm actually pretty excited
because I gained five pounds I mean I'm
I'm so pretty skinny but at least is a
start so there may be mood swings and
you will see a drop in your menstrual
cycle thank God periods have never been
easy on young men
this is the parental consent form which
needs me signed why can't you just be a
lesbian because she's not a lesbian mom
she's a boy do you remember we were
gonna name him Cole if he was a boy and
now she is a boy and her name is Rae
like a truck driver or something Yeah
right let me talk to you for a second
[ __ ] oh my god don't sit down heard
you got into a fight I'm not starting a
new school in this body I'm just not
maybe they'd make an exception I'm done
with being an exception what if he turns
around one day and says mom I made a
mistake Prabang this doesn't keep me a
girl Neal onder just keeps me from being
who I already am something's got to
change
a boy
yes a boy I can't sign this this is just
a formality because you're named on the
birth certificate there are risks she
may not be able to get pregnant
there is no Ramon anymore it's just Ray
there's been a problem with the papers
your father has to sign them but he
won't why does he care he hasn't seen me
since I was a baby
so leave your family and start a new one
I didn't leave my family
I feel pretty left so you like our
brother yeah sorta
why sort of because I was born in a
girl's body I'm the girl in a girl's
body I think
I went through losing my daughter all by
myself and I will be raising my son
exactly the same
I don't hear any slamming Ray's the only
good decision I've ever made
I still vote lesbian apple pies the
other body basically a baddie then
welcome to New York